This video is made possible by Nord VPN take control of your internet experience
today, go to North vpn.com forward slash bar graphics and use our coupon code
biographics app checkouts, and you'll get a special deal.
Every purchase of a two year plan gets you 68% off plus four additional months
for free. And let's get into today's video.
She's one of the longest serving prime ministers in British history as head of
the conservative party. Margaret Thatcher led the UK for a May, 1979, right?
The way through to November of 1990. In that time,
she ushered in an era of reform unparalleled in the 20th century under her
watch, the post-war settlement was torn up. State assets were privatized.
The financial market let rip and to the cultural fabric of Britain changed
beyond recognition,
but the transformations didn't just stop at home alongside her U S counterpart
for Ronald Reagan.
Snapchat helped spread the gospel of economic Liberty and individual freedom
across the entire planet. When she finally left office,
she was widely recognized as the most significant British leader since
Churchill. Yes, while Churchill is still widely loved in the UK.
Margaret Thatcher's legacy is hugely divisive taking over an alien Britain,
her economic shock therapy devastated in Tanya regions,
even as it saved the country as a whole, both worships and reviled at home.
This is the story of Britain's most controversial leader.
[Inaudible].
When Margaret Hilda Roberts was born on October the 13th, 1925,
there was nothing that suggested she would one day lead her nation.
Her father was a grocer and two young Margaret's grew up in achingly modest
circumstances.
The family had no indoor toilet and warm water was an unknown luxury. Yes,
it wasn't a petty voice for our lifestyle alone that made Margaret and unlikely
candidate for future PM.
It was the fact that she was a sheep right up until Fanshawe became education
secretary in 1969,
there were only ever been four female cabinet ministers in UK history and not a
single prime minister as Snapchat herself would say an ITV interview in 1973,
the idea of a woman ever rising beyond the cabinet to become prime minister
seemed impossible still,
despite living in a society that considered casual sexism, a legitimate hobby,
Margaret never really felt she needed to pursue needy like interests.
Her major passion was chemistry,
which she studied at Oxford under the Nobel prize winner, Dorothy Hodgkin,
but even as she was winning plaudits for her science work faccia was discovering
her other lifelong love politics in 1945, the UK,
his first post-war election resulted in a shock when not for Winston Churchill's
conservatives, but for the left-wing labor party of climate.
Antley the labor landslide completely appended Britain in his six years in power
actually created the NHS,
the welfare state and what became known as the post-war settlements and unspoken
agreements between the parties that the state needed to interfere in the
economy. Naturally Sacha hated this one year after athletes took power,
became president of the Oxford university conservative association from where
she railed against the labor tide to transforming Britain. So good.
Was she at this that it soon convinced her to enter politics proper at the 1950
election banter stood as a conservative candidate for the seat of Darfur or
someone who party were appalled at the idea of a lady human running.
She still managed to increase our share of the local vote by 50% and early sign
of a electoral prowess,
but it wasn't enough to win nor did notice enough votes in the 1951 election.
Despite this being the election that saw Churchill and the conservatives
returned to power, yes, all was not lost.
It was through her campaigning in Darfur that Margaret met Dennis Snapchat,
a rich, somewhat dopey guy, Dennis would turn out to be the ideal husband.
He was tremendously supportive of Margaret's ambitions for public office.
And so hands-off, it was like he was permanently wearing a straight jacket.
Although this did have some odd side effects such as when Dennis went to the
cricket rather than interfere in the birth of their children.
He was the solid supportive rock that Margaret needed,
especially now that our interest in politics was becoming an obsession in 1959,
after a few years practicing as a barrister thunderous stood again for election.
This time in the conservative safe seat of Finchley unsurprisingly,
she won most surprisingly.
She soon began to skyrockets up through the party's ranks by 1961.
She had been appointed secretary in the ministry of pensions and national
insurance. Although her party lost power in 1964,
it's new leader to adhese invited her into the shadow cabinet,
sadly not the Tory version of the council of doom,
but what us Brits call the out of power parties, highest ranking members.
Then men's that's when he unexpectedly won the 1970 election,
Margaret Thatcher became only the fifth female cabinet minister in British
history display working for a party full of men.
Who'd never quite immensely removed.
The no girls allowed sign from their tree houses.
Sacha had ascended to one of the top positions in the lands.
Let's all could anyone have known? This was only the start.
[Inaudible].
For anyone living in Britain,
the 1970s being on the world's worst roller coaster.
It was a decade when Britain teetered on the verge of bankruptcy when powerful
unions called strikes that paralyzed the country. But for Margaret Sacha,
it was also the decade when everyone associated her primarily with milk in
1971,
looking to make savings in the education budget Sanchez eliminated a post-war
policy, a free school milk for children. Although it was justifiable,
the optics were so bad that it became a PR disaster for the rest of our 10 year
factual. It was followed everywhere by cries of Thatcher milk snatch up,
but I'm pleasant as this was,
it was nothing compared to what was going on behind the scenes Pacha and Ted
Heath hated one another while it was partly personal.
It was also Satcher being sick of defending her government's dreadful record.
It was under Heath.
The three-day week came in when businesses were only allowed electricity three
days a to conserve energy. As a result,
the conservatives lost both 1974 elections.
Suddenly Sacha was out of governments,
but now the grocer's daughter from Lincoln Cher knew what she had to do.
She had to get rid of Heath these days,
losing an election means stepping down as leader of your party. But back then,
you could keep right on trucking so long as no one challenged you to a
leadership contest. The conservatives being the policy of loyalty,
no one wanted to challenge Heath, except for Thatcher.
The newspapers thought she was out of her mind went that just stood for leader
of the Tories. It was assumed that he would rom home to victory,
but faccia went on the attack, gathering the polities right-wing around her.
She lambasted he dreadful record in February, 1975.
The shock results of the first ballot came in. Sacha had a one.
Now under the conservative parties, weird rules.
This didn't actually make her the leader,
but he could see his position was untenable and he stepped aside.
And just like that thought she became the first female leader of a major UK
party. Not that anyone expected her to rise any further. In 1975,
the labor government was headed by the affable broadly popular Harold Wilson.
So what if stature was making barnstorming anticommunist speeches that earned
the nickname, the iron lady. So what if the Tories were getting better?
A messaging with Wilson leading the labor party. She was probably doomed.
Unfortunately for labor Wilson, wouldn't be around much longer in 1976,
Harold Wilson abruptly resigned as prime minister.
I move now thought to have been brought on by the discovery that he had early
stage Alzheimer's.
His replacement was a charisma void known as James Callahan guy.
It's so inept that he turns a mildly pro-labor country into rabid
Tories. Under Callaghan Britain collapsed in his economic terminal.
What gigantic pay freezes nationwide battles with overpowered unions in late
1978, things culminated in the winter of discontent periods.
When uncollected refuse piled high in the streets and bodies were left on
buried, it was likely the country's post-war low points.
The UK was an ungovernable mess.
It was also exactly what sanction needed on March the 28th,
Margaret Thatcher called a no confidence vote in Callahan's government
triggering an early election. As the campaign heated up,
the conservatives played a blinder plastering London with posters of long dollar
queues under the caption labor isn't working Callaghan.
Meanwhile gave the impression of someone who expected to win because, well, duh,
his opponent was a go on may the third, 1979.
The conservatives won the election by a decent margin. It wasn't a landslide,
but it was definitely enough to comfortably form a government on that date.
Margaret, that trip became not only the UK, his first female prime minister,
but the first female leader of any major Western democracy as she ends at 10
Downing street, the triumphant that just declared.
Well, that is discord. Maybe bring harmony.
To see this wouldn't exactly happen. Now,
before we get on with the trials and tribulations of Ms. Here's a quick word
from our sponsor. Now, if you're online, you really should be using a VPN.
And that's when Nord VPN comes in as tempting not to bond this summit,
we'll just hope for the best,
but really those stories you read about people having their data stolen,
they do happen, and you don't want to make it easy for anyone to do that to you.
Whether it's a nefarious actor,
snooping for your private information or companies tracking your privacy,
but a VPN is not so much more. For example,
Nord VPN lets you access any of its thousands of sevens in different countries,
all around the globe. So if you've hit the end of your Netflix queue,
simply try changing the location of your server and get access to content
libraries that do the licensing agreements are only available in specific
geographic locations.
I ran into that in the past with mad men and a few other shows as well,
nor VPN is super fast. So watching video is a breeze.
If you've ever used VPNs and thought they were slow, well,
no more with Nord and you can use it on all of your devices. Very easily,
Android Chrome windows, Linux,
and on six different devices with just one accounts.
Also there are no logs because Nord is based in Panama,
unlike companies in the U S and the UK,
they just don't have to keep logs at all.
So take control of your internet experience. Now go to Nord,
vpn.com forward slash biographics and use our coupon biographics of checkout.
And you will get a special deal.
Every purchase of a two year plan gets you 68% off plus four additional months
for free. And let's get back to today's video.
[Inaudible].
In 82 dawns,
it looked like Britain's first female PM was doomed to be a one-term.
One up in the first year is in power. Thatcher had sent out a governing style,
antagonistic determines destructive in a weird way.
She was like a 2010s tech mogul. Someone who disrupted, who broke stuff,
who assembled something from the wreckage of the old, during a later terms,
the economic gains from this destruction would be enough to keep middle England
on the side. But as a first time, swamped by those games had yet to materialize.
All anyone could see was the destruction.
More businesses were failing than at any time since the great depression,
unemployment was at record breaking highs, privatization of state assets.
It's so far cost tens of thousands of jobs,
but not yet brought visible benefits.
This slider famous declaration in October of 1980,
thus the ladies not for turning Sanchez,
closest advisors were secretly urging her to make a gigantic U-turn lest the
Tories be stomped at the 1983 election.
And it was onto this sinking ship that Argentina suddenly through a gigantic
lifesaver and okay, let's just have a quick geography lesson.
Now down in the South Atlantic,
about 483 kilometers off the Argentine coast lines, the Falkland islands,
despite being nearly 13,000 kilometers from London,
they've been a British territory since at least 1833 by 1982, though,
the Falklands were only home to a declining population of 1,800 people.
Although Britain still claims the territory. It refused to invest.
That ends the, of the type of successive.
That being that the Islanders would voluntarily accept Argentinian silver and D
at some point in the future.
But the military junta in Buenos Aires was tired of waiting on April the second,
1982, they occupied the Falklands a few days later,
they also took the British territory of South Georgia.
The Hunter assumed London was too broke to unwilling to send soldiers to die for
the sake of a godforsaken rock. On the other side of the world, they went Eddie,
right when news broke,
the cabinets feeling was that the Falklands would have to be surrendered,
but the Hunter hadn't counted on Fetcher egged on by the Navy founders declared
war in Argentina,
a Royal Navy flew flotilla was sent to retake the islands without the Falklands
war began today.
It's almost impossible to overstate the effects the short war had on Thatcher's
popularity. Remember how George W.
Bush his approval rating hit 92% often nine 11? Well,
something similar happens here.
Fetches resolute defense of British territory struck a chord with ordinary
citizens.
It helps that the war was short lasting in our 74 days before Argentina
surrendered.
And that it was a very one-sided 649 Argentine troops were killed
versus 255 British troops, but make no mistake.
The iron will fascia displayed in the face of foreign aggression,
made her a hero.
It's elevated our profile on the international stage already allied with us,
president Ronald Reagan.
She now started to look like as equal come the 1983 election facture
crushed labor in a landslide with a powerful new mandate.
The gloves were lost off over the next two times.
Margaret nacho was going to change person beyond all recognition.
[Inaudible].
The second time began with a powerful message appointing Ian McGregor,
head of the national coal board. Back in 1979,
Thatcher had hired McGregor to make the state owns British steel profitable.
Again, McGregor had achieved this at the loss of 95,000 jobs under the economic
devastation of entire towns.
Now SAMSHA was asking him to do the same thing for the alien coal industry,
but while British steel had folded to McGregor's on will,
coal was going to be much tougher.
The national union of minors was Britain's most powerful union at a time when
unions could break an entire premier ship,
it was the num in 1973 that had exacerbated the three-day week
leading to Ted heat's downfall. Now they were looking to do the same to shot.
Unfortunately for the num Fancher had brought to this figurative.
NIFA is not just a gun, but a bazooka on March the sixth,
1984, a local strike at caught in corollary was used by anyone president Arthur
Scargill to force a general strike across the nation. But Tasha was prepared.
Cold had been secretly stockpiled non-unionized firms were hired to do strike
breaking police forces were prime to fight the battle was on,
and it really was a battle or rather a series of battles.
The West took place at Audrey when a police jog into a crowd of strikers led to
123 serious injuries, but the main weapon Sandra deployed wasn't truncheons.
But time as the strike dragged on, laws were passed.
That stops the families of striking miners from receiving welfare. And in fact,
fascia starved her enemies into submission and submit they did on March the
third, 1985,
that strike was called off the miners returned to work broken over the next
decade McGregor and his success closed all but 15 of Britain's,
174 deep pits.
The economic engine of entire regions was wiped out,
leaving jobless wastelands with num defeated the days of big unions,
bringing Britain to a standstill where over below Thatcher won this war just as
she had the Falklands.
The other great war of a premiership would prove to the unwinnable.
The troubles were an undeclared civil war in Northern Ireland,
the pitted majority Protestant unionists who wanted to stay in the UK against
majority Catholic Republicans who wanted to join Ireland proper.
When Sacha took power, the troubles had already been running for a decade,
but they were about to get much worse.
Things really kicked off on August the 27th, 1979.
When the IRA first assassinated a member of the Royal family,
Lord Mountbatten before killing 18 British soldiers in a double bomb attack.
But that his biggest test came in March of 1981 that month IRA prisoners,
including member of parliament,
Bobby sens began a hunger strike to force the British state to treat them as
prisoners of war.
The thoughts horrified Thatcher who declared the men were common criminal saying
crime is crime is crime.
It is not political by the time October rolled around 10 of the hunger strikers
were dead and then mistreatment and turn them into international celebrities.
It, it also turns stature into a Republican hate figure. On the 12th of October,
1984, an IRA bomb at the conservative conference in Brighton killed five people.
Santura escaped on harms and made a speech.
The following day vowing to fight on.
She hopes to inflict a decisive victory on the forces of republicanism. Instead,
the troubles went supernova over the next few years.
The IRA bombed civilians skills,
policemen with mortars and even assassinated patches, friends,
the conservative MP in gal.
It wouldn't be until Facciola left office that the troubles would come to an
end. Thanks to the work of her successes, John major and Tony Blair.
Although it was far from the defining theme of her premiership Sanchez failed
attempt to defeat the IRA showed the limits of the iron ladies power.
Sometimes just sometimes perhaps the lady should have been for turning
The Wars and anti union crusades.
Maggie was also overseeing a social revolution, Thatcherism preached hard work,
personal responsibility and economic liberalism.
It promised a world in which anyone could become well off provided.
They were happy to roll up their sleeves.
While this may have seemed a joke to those in depressed former mining towns,
it was true for enough people to keep her in power.
One of the most popular policies was right to buy,
which allowed those in council housing to save up and buy the place for
themselves.
But the biggest rewards fell to those who profited from the big bang.
As early as 1979,
fascia had begun loosening regulations in London's financial sector,
leading to a lot of people becoming very rich, but it was on October the 27th,
1986, that things really took off. That was the day.
The city was almost completely deregulated allowing things like foreign firms to
own UK brokers and demolishing the fixed commission on trades overnight.
The big bang made 1,500 million as it created iconic districts like
London's Canary Wharf skyscrapers began to sprout out money poured in.
It was the transformation of the financial sector from the bowler hat wearing
old boys club of yesteryear into the turbo capitalist free for all of today.
Yes,
ventures revolution went beyond the mere confines of Britain under our watch.
The UK became a global player in a way.
It simply hadn't been since Churchill left office in 1994, for example,
Thatcher began courting Mikhail Gorbachev even before he became Soviet leader
during a visit to Britain Gorbachev famously had a six hour argument with Sacha
over the benefits and ills of communism when they were done that just declared.
We can do business together and set about becoming both Gorbachev's best friends
and worst enemy in the West,
Virginia skeptical Ronald Reagan to work with a new Soviet premier.
Not that she'd let Russia push her around though.
Invited to the Soviet union in 1987,
bachelor winds on live TV and spend an hour talking about all the USSR failings
for citizens and communist nations.
That speech was like seeing someone articulate everything they'd been feeling
for decades. Fascia became an overnight celebrity in the Eastern block.
Even today, countries like the Czech Republic,
consider her a British hero on par with Churchill, but there were missteps too,
in the last part of the 1980s,
Thatcher vehemently opposed sanctions against South Africa's apartheid regime.
She considered Nelson Mandela, typical terrorist and proudly boasted.
That Britain was the only Commonwealth nation still trading with the white
supremacist state. Ouch. Yes,
there were also surprised moments when she broke her own party's line.
In the late 1980s,
she became one of the first world leaders to sound the alarm on climate change,
helping push for a world environment funds the preservation of rainforests and
the introduction of emissions targets. Overall.
Then there was enough popular staff in the financial programs who ensure that
she cruised to an easy victory in 1987,
becoming the UK is only 20th century leader to serve three terms.
And still she seemed destined to go on.
There was even talk of her winning a possible fourth term,
but it was not to be the woman who had overhauled Britain had already sowed the
seeds of our own destruction. When the ends finally came,
it was going to be with a swiftness that shocked everybody.
Indians.
What brought factor down was what has brought down every single conservative
prime minister since Europe on January,
the first 1973 tat Heath had taken Britain into what was the European economic
community, a move confirmed by a 1975 referendum come the 1980s,
the conservatives were still mostly a pro Europe party, at least in theory,
unlike our MPS Fancher was rabidly anti Europe. At first,
this was something that MPS managed as best. They could.
It even occasionally brought benefits when Thatcher reduced Britain's budget
contributions in 1984, but it soon became a major liability.
As the consonants integrated further,
Estancia became a vocal Euro-skeptic rallying against the consonance leaders.
This would be fine if she had managed to get a party on side,
but official policy remained pro Europe. In fact,
Snapchat was sabotaging her own governments. There was a,
was a string of senior ministers resigning,
all contributing to a perception that the Tories were becoming dangerously and
competence.
Then just as this gigantic pile of fertilizer was starting to look extremely
combustible. Fascia threw an unrelated match onto it.
The poll tax is why Scotland is to this day. Passionately anti Tori,
a political move designed to deprive labor councils of revenue.
It's abolished local tax rates. Instead levying a flat tax on every adult.
They don't show it walls that the rich saw their bills plummet while the
middle-class is the very backbone of the Thatcherite revolutions.
All their costs go shooting up in 1999.
That's a pint as it is in Scotland ahead of a rollout across England and Wales,
it was a disaster. There were protests mass acts of civil disobedience.
By 1990 over 1 million had refused to pay ministers begged Snapchat,
not to push ahead with the hate attacks, but like a latter day, George,
the third Thatcher insisted on it on March 31st,
1990 central London was devastated by an anti poll tax rot that summit
discontent brewed across the nation. Sadly by now,
Maggie had become a caricature of herself. She was the iron lady,
not for turning, even when turning would have saved her political career.
Things finally came to a head in October,
following a European summit on integration.
Facture gave an angry speech in which she replied to the idea.
We, they shouted no, no.
In response to the pro Europe cabinet member,
Jeffrey Howe resigned for such a measure. Man,
his resignation speech was devastating.
Concluding that the party needed to question it's all due to fascia.
That's another time Patrick could have shrugged it off, but in 1990,
with Paul tank's RANTES burning across the country and a pro European party fed
up with a Euro skepticism. She was typist on November the 15th,
the year of our conservative Michael Haston tine did what Fancher had herself
done to Heath. All those years ago. He challenged her to a leadership contest.
And when the results came in, factual was doomed.
Although she got the most votes,
it had been by a pitiable margin as the two headed into the second round.
So the venture realized you have profound shock that she might lose.
So she jumped before she was pushed at 7:30 AM on November the 22nd,
1990 Margaret Thatcher resigned as prime minister.
At the moment she stepped down.
She was the longest continuously serving prime minister since 1827.
She was also one of the two most influential post-war PMs setting,
an economic that has pretty much lost it intact until today only Clement
Attlee really comes close in terms of significance.
And it was his long lasting post-war settlements that Thatcher ripped up. Yes,
despite her continued significance,
despite her achievements opening the door to future female leaders just spends
her years out of office bitter and unhappy.
She fumed over her betrayal by her party fumes over the creation of the EU
with nowhere left to channel her prodigious energies.
She turned inwards by two thousands.
She was showing signs of the dementia that would soon consumer just as outsiders
had consumed Harold Wilson before her, by the ends,
the dementia rented her mute almost incapable of doing even the simplest action.
It said she liked to spend our days staring at a painting of a Victorian hunting
party. Not really doing anything,
just watching the crowd of painted dogs for signs of life.
Margaret Thatcher passed away on April the eighth, 2013,
while the welds mourns the death of a great leader.
The reaction in Britain itself,
a town's devastated by her economic policies still haven't recovered.
It was more mixed.
That's why he is the number two record in the British chart was ding dong.
The witch is dead yet for all the bile,
many Egypt upon her for all the hatred she stirred up.
His legacy is all around us.
It's from a Euro skepticism that the forces grew that would unleash Brexit from
her wave of deregulation.
That today's city of London was created almost every facet of modern life that
we Brits take for granted the depressed post-industrial towns,
the special relationship with America,
the lack of paralyzing French style strikes all have their roots and naturalism
in the ends. Then the good and the bad of our legacy are impossible to separate.
She was who she was with a blind faith to do both necessary things for Britain's
future and to commit screw ups that still holding the nation to this day in a
world without Maggie Thatcher, many would be worse off.
Some would be better off, but all would be able to agree on one thing.
They were living in a completely different world from us. One in which Britain,
Europe, and the former nations of the Soviet union had very different fates.
If greatness is measured purely in terms of impact,
then that surely an exa one of the greatest prime ministers of all.
So I really hope you did find that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe.
I'll see you next time.